let's start
all right um welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone let's go over some logistics uh
first please mute your yourself during
the talk unless you have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
meet and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in q a session at the
end
second today's gdps seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host jess
kappa cilantro who is an
assistant professor in the department of
mechanical engineering and aerospace
engineering at the university of
michigan his research group develops
numerical methods and data-driven
approaches for the prediction and
optimization
of
messy
turbulent flows relevant to energy and
the environment
often multiphase and reacting
prior to joining michigan in 2016 dr
cappa cilantro
was a research scientist at the center
for exascale simulation of plasma
coupled combustion at the university of
illinois
he received a
bachelor's in science from sunni
binghampton in 2009 a master in science
from the university of colorado boulder
in 2011 and phd from
cornell in 2014. he is a recipient of
the national science foundation
career award office of naval research
young investigator award and the asme
pai tau sigma gold medal award
all right today
dr cappa cilantro
will present an interesting topic which
is turbulent dispersed two phase flows
simulations and data-driven modeling
please enjoy and expect a
a wonderful talk now without further ado
let me press the button
by asking one random question as usual
today's random question is what is your
favorite sports team if you have any
it's question for you guys
okay
um
i grew up in new york and i i watched a
lot of uh professional football and so
it's a new york giants fan but
but um
yeah
most of the sports i do now is a rock
climbing ultimate frisbee and there's
not a lot of uh
professional teams so
uh yeah i don't follow much sports
anymore but used to be a giants fan
thank you thank you jess it's all yours
okay thanks so uh it's really an honor
to be here this seminar series has been
um i've been i've i've attended a couple
of them and the lineup of speakers has
been really fantastic so it's been a
silver lining of this pandemic to uh
um
to be able to to watch and see these uh
the seminars in this series
so
the talk today is is going to be on
dispersed two-phase flows namely gas gas
solid or gas particle flows and i like
this image here this is from our
collaborator um vahid who was at iowa
state worked with chenkar subramaniam
and we work closely with now looking at
a direct numerical simulation through a
suspension of particles and i like to
show this on the title slide because
um
it's just a good image to have in your
mind when we talk about this these types
of flows where particles have an order
one effect on on the background
turbulence and so uh you can see here
that there's um deflection of the stream
lines there's wake shed past the
particles and that's going to have an
order one effect on on the background
flow and that those are the those are
the types of flows we'll be talking
about today
um so as was mentioned our group
we tend to look at we're a computational
group here at michigan
i think everything we do
is under the umbrella of turbulence we
do turbulent combustion i have a student
looking at adjoint based optimization
which i know there might be folks in the
audience here interested in that um
but the talk today is focused on some of
the multi-phase turbulence modeling that
uh work we've been doing the past couple
years
but uh probably that my biggest focus
now is on compressible gas particle
flows which i'm not presenting today but
it's a very i think exciting area of
research there's been a lot of
developments these past even just one to
two years
um
and uh so i'm currently working on a
review article on on compressible gas
particle flows on on the modeling aspect
so it's i think it's a very exciting
area i'm happy to talk about that
offline uh the work i'm presenting today
is funded by nsf and it's mostly i'm
mostly presenting work by my postdoc
aaron latanzi
um
on some of the stochastic modeling he's
been doing for drag
and uh sarah who's uh in the audience
here who is it for us she just just
defended her phd and is a new faculty
member at oakland university in michigan
uh and so most of the stuff on the
multi-phase turbulence modeling is is
her work
and uh this has been uh research we've
done in collaboration with shane carr
subramaniam his student vahed
who's now florida state and rodney fox
so
turbulent dispersed two-phase flows are
you know
ubiquitous uh it's it's there are many
different applications here i'm just
highlighting a couple simulations that
we've done um
in the past uh a couple of years so some
of the types of photos we're interested
in just to give sort of an idea of you
know the
how you know the type of physics
that's present in the vast range of of
applications so uh this is from
exploratory flows obviously related uh
cover 19. um a lot of the flows we're
talking about today is motivated by um
conversion of uh
catalytic particles
aiding the conversion of fuel to useful
uh or sorry feedstock to useful fuels so
one example is biomass pyrolysis
um but a lot of our work has been with
with nasa who's interested in plume
surface interactions so this is a euler
lagrange simulation of an underexpanded
jet on a bed of particles
and uh we
there's a lot of challenges with these
types of simulations we've been doing a
lot of modeling and method development
for
in the compressible regime
so
the talk today
we want to look at turbulence modeling
of what i call strongly coupled flows
and so as an example i want to
distinguish this with the more
classically studied uh particle inflow
and the dilute limit and so what i'm
showing here on the left is a classic
example where you have a heavy inertial
particle solid particle
in a turbulent flow where the volume
fraction epsilon p is very small the
density ratio is very high so think you
know gas solid order of 1000 2000
uh but in this case the the particle
diameter smaller than the the smallest
scales of turbulence and there's a lot
known that
you get preferential concentration you
have enhanced settling as particles
preferentially sampled certain size
regions of the turbulence of eddies
um
and there's there's a lot of really nice
work on on that regime
the flow regime we're interested in
today is sort of we're still looking at
gas solid so large density ratio but now
we're looking at finite volume fraction
so for example this image on the right
is a experiment
done at the national energy technology
lab the doe lab um and i think this was
at about one or five percent
concentration on average and so instead
so here you know the volume fractions
we're talking about going to vary
between 1 and 10
and the particle reynolds number the
reynolds number based on the the
particle diameter can be ordered 10. and
you can see
that there's these there's a lot of
interesting dynamics you get these large
scale clusters that form and unlike in
the dilute limit on the left
here uh the particles really have a
large effect on the background flow and
that introduces a lot of challenges for
for turbulence modeling
um
so the next three slides i shamelessly
stole from my from uh sarah's phd thesis
but you know the main idea here is that
uh the challenge is really that the
classic
uh uh energy cascade
that we'd see in in single phase flow
sort of breaks down because
now the particles will induce wakes at
the smallest small scales
or if they um assemble into clusters
they can induce very large scale wakes
um that that introduces energy at the
small scale that can then cascade back
up and so that's
one one place where where um you know
the classical theories of turbulence
starts to break down when you have these
denser suspensions
so
there's a nice
you know history of the development of
turbulence modeling starting from the uh
sort of the turn of the the 20th century
the uh um
the so-called boosnesque approximation
uh and the and the eddie viscosity model
i'm sure many people here are familiar
with this kamagrav hypothesis so the the
energy cascade and using that in the
context of large eddy simulation has has
been very successful
in the 1970s the development of tensor
basis and so um in invariant basis sets
were developed and uh um which is
required for uh rand's modeling and and
the latter half of this talk is going to
be focused on multi-phase rants modeling
so we're going to really make use of
this
um and the so-called k epsilon model
which is you know really the workhorse
today in a lot of a lot of sectors
um but what we see is there's been a
lull over some time and then in the
2000s and really i you know as
everyone's aware the last just couple of
years um data-driven modeling has
exploded right and so uh this has taken
forms of closure modeling uncertainty
quantification model augmentation and
most often in the context of of neural
networks um
the approach we take is going to be
um
an alternative to neural networks and
i'll explain that a little later
compared to single-phase turbulence
modeling multi-phase turbulence modeling
has really seen a
it really lags the development so
starting really in the 1980s there's
been a lot of models proposed based on
at least multi-phase rans models
proposed that were largely derived from
extensions of single-phase
turbulence
and
in 2014 our collaborator rodney fox
derived uh rigorously the the reynolds
averaged uh two fluid equations and i'll
show sort of that process a little later
um but this leads to a very large number
of unclosed terms that
you a simple augmentation of a single
phase model just won't work because
they're in terms of drag and volume
fraction that just don't exist in single
phase flows
so
so today's talk i i've broken it up into
two parts the first part is on some of
some new developments in our group on
us
on modeling and simulation so this is uh
specifically focusing on a new
stochastic drag force to
capture some of the detailed physics at
the micro scale
and then the latter half is going to use
that modeling sort of framework which
we'll call sort of it's an intermediate
step between the dns and and rans
using data from these simulations in
order to develop multi-phase rance
models
okay so a couple of preliminaries
the way i've i've
decided to
frame this this talk was um instead of
doing a deep dive and really talk
in detail about the the way we do the
data-driven modeling um i thought it
might be
more interesting or at least
helpful to really talk about some of the
physics first and and uh motivate why
you know these data-driven approaches
are um
uh
you know show
show promise and are needed compared to
more classical classical approaches and
so it won't be till that towards the end
that we'll actually talk about some of
the uh
more machine learning type of stuff but
that's uh
the data driven aspect will be will
definitely be relevant throughout
so to begin um for this talk the flows
we're interested in we have uh
solid particles we'll assume are rigid
and spherical in an incompressible flow
so the nice thing is that we know those
equations
the nivea stokes equations
with appropriate boundary conditions at
the surface of each particle
it describes these systems well i have
an asterisk here because when you have
melting or devolazation
other phase change aspects this is
challenging but but for at least for
isothermal or inert particles
the equations are known
and you can see that the the force the
fluid force on the particle shows up
through this fluid stress tensor
integrated at the surface of the
particle
which obviously requires sub-particle
scale resolution so if we wanted to do a
dns we would need to implement some type
of same horse boundary method that i'm
showing here with a resolution smaller
than the particle and uh when i
initially created these slides you know
the state of the art at the time was
ordered 10 of the three
um there's been some recent papers
looking at larger scale simulations so
so uh more particles that are fully
resolved though typically
sacrificing the number of grid points
across the diameter and so it's it's
still very challenging to get more than
a thousand fully resolved particles
so
the alternative approach you know
whatever modeling approach we decide to
take inevitably will require some type
of averaging right so we have to solve
an average set of equations um to look
to be able to simulate larger scales
which inevitably leads to unresolved or
some good scale terms that need to be
modeled
and so
sort of the idea here is that fluid
stress tensor right so this is this is
comprised of pressure and viscous stress
we can think of applying an average or
filter to it
that's what i'm showing in this uh tau
bar
and that averaging operation has a
length scale that's larger than the
particle and so we can pull it outside
this integral
and so this represents
fluid forces acting on the particle
based on the larger resolved scale and
then we have everything left over and
it's not difficult to show
all everything left over i.e the fluid
stresses at the particle scale is exact
is is essentially the drag force
and so in order to close the system of
equations or at least this equation here
we need to introduce a model for this
unresolved fluid stress near the along
the surface of the particle and you know
a classic classic closure is that from
george stokes um who proposed in the
limit of a small reynolds number an
isolated particle um we have a mod
stokes drag that's shown here
uh now obviously if we have a um
accelerating uh either reference frame
or accelerating particles or there's
non-uniform flow effects
additional terms appear besides just
stoke's drag and so what i'm showing
here is that it's the so-called bbo
equations so particles might exhibit an
added mass force uh specifically for
lower density ratio or bubbly flows a
bass a history term this is really due
to delayed boundary layer development
again it's it's usually small for gas
solid um and then this the so-called
quasi-steady drag force which is where
stokes drag would
but for these denser suspensions when we
have neighbor effects right one
particle's wake might interact with
another particle's wake
we get volume fraction effects or finite
reynolds number effects you can't
readily apply um such an equation
and so the idea then is
again we have this newton's second law
this ode for the particle position it
fuels a resolved stress this is
sometimes referred to as the undisturbed
force or the pressure gradient force
and then a uh um this fd is everything
left over which is usually closed with
uh correlations from either experiments
or simulations and so
in the last probably
10 20 years or
yeah i guess some of the first dns
simulations about 20 years ago
um
several models have have been developed
the idea is you have a box of particles
you fully resolve it you play a mean
pressure gradient and then you in these
simulations the drag is an output
and then you you run a bunch of
simulations you come up with
correlations and so one popular drag
model is by uh tinnetti garg and
subramaniam from 2011
where you have a drag force over this
represents the average drag force in
that suspension and it's correlated
based on the mean reynolds number and
the volume fraction
and this is really um
commonly applied in most modern codes i
mean the idea of applying a gi
correlation to particles is standard
practice
every commercial software with particles
does this now some of the challenges
though is that
when you go to larger scales or when you
have some of these complex flows
or high reynolds number flows
this drag correlation really represents
the mean
but there could be significant deviation
about that mean and at very large scales
you can have clustering and not and
heterogeneity existing that this drag
such drag correlations just can't
capture and
work by out of anthony wax's group along
with a balachandar's group from florida
have published a number of papers where
they show that the db
the variation about that mean
is quite large and so what this is
showing is if we have a suspension of
particles you look at a pdf of the drag
force you know the existing correlations
work pretty well to capture the mean um
but the the standard deviation can be
just as large as the mean which is uh um
clearly not accounted for an existing
models
and
using existing drag laws tends to fail
at least it's difficult to capture some
important statistics like the particle
velocity variance or the dispersion and
the main idea is if you can imagine
having three scenarios so here i have a
grid cell each grid cell has the same
reynolds number right i have the same
mean velocity and particle velocity and
the same volume fraction each one has
four particles but this particle in
green should experience a significantly
different drag force depending on the
orientation of its neighbors um and so
but using standard drag correlations
would predict that these particles all
have the same drag force so that that's
what the where the issue comes from
uh now there's been
over the last uh five years i'd say a
lot of focus on how to improve these
drag laws there's been some nice work
from bala shandar trying to do this
deterministically
where you loop through neighboring
particles and try to map or superimpose
the effect of neighbors on on that
particle of interest but we've decided
to take a different route the main idea
here is that each particle will
experience both a uh it's the drag force
on on this particle i will have a
contribution from sort of the mean drag
that's that's where you know an existing
drag correlation would give plus what's
left over
and that would be given by some
distribution
and it turns out that
previous simulations have shown that
that pdf tends to be gaussian which is
convenient
and so the way we're just we're modeling
the the
variation in that drag force is using
the langevin equation so
applying a language equation of the
force results in orange signal and back
process
and here we can see the increment
incremental change in the the drag force
has these two terms here
um which require which requires closure
this tau f
is an integral time scale of the the
fluid force fluctuations and the sigma f
represents the standard deviation
and uh here w is a wiener process or
essentially a gaussian white noise
and work we've been doing from
extracting these statistics from dns
shows that this is a
a good approximation of what's going on
because we can the drag force is indeed
gaussian
and um the autocorrelation and the force
fluctuations is indeed exponential and
so treating this force as a language
mean equation is uh should be promising
and allow us to to capture uh important
statistics
a side note is um
we treat the
it's a lot more common to treat the
velocity statistically so so this
usually in most you know fluent or open
foam
these so-called random walk models tries
to
uh plug in the fluid velocity that's not
known as a stochastic variable uh what
we're finding is if you treat the force
stochastically instead of the velocity
you can guarantee certain statistics but
more than that it
results in the velocity to be markovian
process which is which means that
there's promise of doing such an
approach
um to capture history effects like added
mass and so one thing we're interested
in now is looking at stochastic added
mass
um but this is this is sort of how it
works
our particle will feel forces due to
collisions maybe gravity the resolved
stress so that's the pressure gradient
force um and then what's left over
what's left over is going to be uh the
mean drag which we can model with
existing correlations
and then the uh fluctuating part
the mean drag we already have
correlation so that's good the
fluctuating part is is described with
this ou process
we have found in our previous work that
that time scale is is reasonably
predicted using the time between
successive collisions and from kinetic
theory um we we have a model for that
this is based on the granular
temperature and the radial distribution
function and so
we readily have a model for this term
but we need a model for the standard
deviation
and looking at
particle resolve simulations it turns
out we can get a nice collapse across
volume fraction and across
reynolds numbers if we normalize the
standard deviation with the drag force
for an isolated particle and so now we
have a closed form expression for that
for all of the terms in that model
uh and and briefly we just want to see
well how well does it work and how does
it compare against uh existing methods
um so
uh what we do is we're looking at two
canonical systems so the so-called
homogeneous cooling and homogeneous
heating case so imagine you have a box
of particles there's no walls
and you force a flow through there if
the particles are at rest
eventually its granular temperature or
the velocity variance of the particles
will increase and reach some steady
value so that's the heating case
alternatively if the particles start
with some finite variance and finding
velocity fluctuations it'll cool to some
steady state
and what we're showing here is uh that
granular temperature or velocity
variance uh normalized gives us a
reynolds number based on the the
granular temperature as a function of
time
the symbols are data from dns
now just a side note that if you recall
the closure we used one was based on
kinetic theory for the time between
successive collisions and one was based
on the standard deviation of the force
which was taken from fixed particle
assemblies so and we're comparing this
model to
dns of freely evolving particles and so
this is very much not an exercise of
tuning any parameters
it's truly it's a true prediction
and what we see
is the red is the
oil of the grange method
with the langevin force the stochastic
force and we see we we both capture this
the transient behavior in addition to
this the steady state whereas the blue
is showing the standard approach where
you you only have the mean force which
is unable to capture those fluctuations
and similarly across reynolds numbers
and volume fractions this is the heating
case starting with
uh particles are immobile you force a
flow through and they their velocity
fluctuations increase and eventually
level off we see very good agreement
um so this is just uh
a new model that we've been developing
and it's also showing promise
looking at lower density ratio uh
suspension so looking at bubbly flows as
well
but you know the title of the talk was
on turbulence modeling and so
what i'd like to do is now zoom out and
look at some larger scale systems right
this box of particles you know we're
talking about i think on the order of
100 particles very small scale
um
but let's zoom out and so as a
representative example this is the uh
that um chemical looping reactor where i
showed that image earlier from that
fluid in his bed
and uh you know
i just want to reiterate that
this is very challenging when it comes
to turbulence modeling because at the
smallest scales you have collisions you
have wakes past particles if there's
heat transfer you can have a
convection or conduction
and what happens at the small scales
feeds back to the large scales in terms
of clustering and that has an order one
effect on the background turbulence
and so what we're going to do is
first derive a set of intermediate
equations and that these are the
equations we're solving in the
homogeneous heating and cooling uh for
the model so the fluid phase we uh if
you locally average the nivea stokes
equations you get a new set of equations
that look very similar except now we
have fluid volume fraction appearing
in addition to that in the momentum
equation we have um this phi is mass
loading and so this is just the relative
mass of the particle the fluid phase
and then we have our interphase exchange
so this is how the fluid feels the
effect of
drag from the particles so it feels both
the drag force
and the
resolve stresses
now the the idea here is taking those
equations
uh instead of the original lava stokes
equations and applying an averaging
operation to that will allow us to
retain more physics and so the idea here
is what we're going to do the usual
reynolds averaging but because there's
volume fractions that pop up in lots of
places
we're going to do so-called phase
averaging this is analogous to far of
averaging for variable density flows but
here we have volume fraction instead of
density
and so we could define a residual about
the mean so a double prime is a
fluctuation about the phase average
fluid
and then the triple prime or
fluctuations about the uh
sorry the double prime is the
fluctuation about the particle phase
phase average and the triple prime is
based on the fluid
and uh you can imagine doing this to the
navy stocks equation is going to lead to
a lot of unclosed terms so i want to
just highlight one example where we have
a channel flow meaning we have one
non-homogeneous direction
that'll be the wall normal direction and
other terms will cancel out the home the
derivatives and the homogeneous
directions cancel out
and what we end up with is
a reynolds average equation so this
looks should look very similar to what
we'd have in single phase channel flow
if we got rid of these terms in red
and so the terms in blue are unclosed
terms that appear in the rental stress
model
due to pressure redistribution
production due to mean shear so due to
mean gradients and a dissipation rate so
this is exactly what appears for single
phase turbulence
but the terms in red are new and this is
uh new in the sense they wouldn't exist
if there were no particles so we have a
so-called drag dissipation and exchange
rate so this
is how
fluid turbulent kinetic energy is
transferred between the phases and you
can see it's proportional to the mass
loading so the limit of low volume
fraction this goes to zero
and then we have a drag production term
so this shows this is an interesting
term because in homogeneous flows we
have no mean gradients
um you would have no production of tke
because the the this p shear term would
be zero but this shows that in the
presence of particles through coupling
from drag you can get production of tke
even in the absence of mean shear
and this ud is based on is a drift
velocity so it's the mean phase
difference so in order for particles to
induce
turbulence in the fluid
you need two ingredients you need finite
mass loading
so particles need to have
the high enough volume fraction and high
enough density
and you need to have locally a non-zero
mean slip velocity
so that's that's what drives turbulence
in the particle phase
and and the idea here is
um we want to avoid going from the
microscale directly averaging the niber
stokes equations because that's going to
end up lumping a lot of important
physics into
a very small number of unclosed terms
and instead go from the microscale to
inform these mesoscale equations and
then the mesoscale apply that averaging
um and then use that to inform the
closure for the macroscale equations
so here's just an example
where we're solving this is uh in our
in-house code um it's a you know pretty
vanilla finite volume second order uh uh
low mach number uh uh solver with
lagrangian particle tracking here we're
solving those volume filtered equations
so it's the niagara stokes with the
volume fraction and momentum exchange
terms
and what we see is we have a turbulent
channel flow reynolds number is ten
thousand density ratio is two thousand
and if we look in the case of a very
dilute flow
the uh fluid velocity resembles what we
might expect for a single phase flow and
if we look at the budget of tke you get
a balance between the shear production
and viscous dissipation
now if you keep everything the same
but we only add more particles such that
our mass loading is now order one here
at the mass loading's two
there's enhanced dissipation through
drag through that drag exchange term
which re-laminarizes the flow and you
can see the budget's completely killed
off
and if we keep adding particles and now
our mass loading is 20. again this is a
3d simulation i'm just showing a 2d
cross section
the
coupling between the phases leads to
clustering and the clustering leads to
large scale wakes and now we see fluid
tke but it's a very different
characteristic than the single phase
turbulence and here the budget we have
drag production balanced by drag
exchange so
um here you know reynolds number is
constant the only thing changing is the
mass loading and we have very different
uh flow characteristics
uh another interesting thing is if we
look at the uh spectrum of tke
uh up here is the single phase case so
the classic k to the minus five thirds
and in the dilute limit you can see that
particles are really enhancing the tke
at the largest wave numbers so that
really represents um you know the wakes
past individual particles but as you
increase the mass loading and you get
clustering the particles have a
broadband effect and the tke is reduced
across with numbers
okay
uh
the final part of this talk i just want
to talk about
looking at how we develop closure models
for the reynolds average terms
and uh i want to focus on what i would
consider the simplest possible
case that's driven by coupling with the
particles so
the channel case is a great that it just
showed is a is a nice
uh uh framework uh for looking at these
effects of particles on the turbulence
but because of that wall normal
direction it leads to a bunch of terms
and so to simplify things we're going to
consider a homogeneous box of particles
so it's triply periodic particles are
randomly distributed and uh
they're the fluids initially at rest and
we have gravity and because of gravity
particles start to settle
and here we're in the frame of reference
of the fluid so we force the mass flow
rate to be zero
and due to the coupling uh particles
will spontaneously form these dense
clusters and we can see here the fluid
velocity now
we have these high speed vertical flow
in between clusters meanwhile the
clusters uh entrain the the
flow downward and so in the absence of
particles the flow would be at rest and
here the fluid tke is entirely due to
the coupling
uh and we're going to consider a couple
different cases so um different volume
fractions from point one percent to five
percent um which corresponds the mass
loading between one and fifty
and uh
what we wanna do is evaluate those uh
those unclosed terms that appear so
that's the drag production term is one
of the primary ones
and before i joined michigan this was
this is work i was doing with rodney fox
i spent two summers in france on this
work
and it became apparently clear that you
know there's a large number of terms and
there's a huge dimensional space right
so unlike in single phase flow where you
really have a reynolds number here we
have density ratio volume fraction
a bunch of extra terms and direct
coming up with robust closure models has
been quite challenging and so the work
that's my student sarah former student
sarah has been doing is is looking at um
using some data-driven approaches to
come up with model closure and the
approach we decided to take was we
wanted to have a model that ends up with
a nice algebraic form so we wanted to
avoid using neural networks because we
wanted to have an algebraic expression
for these terms
we also wanted to make sure that it had
important and embedded important physics
for example form and variance
uh and so this
what this follows is essentially a
sparse regression technique that i'm
sure a lot of people here are familiar
with um and the idea here is we we take
some tensorial data so this would be
data that can come from either
simulations or experiments in this case
from the from the euler lagrange
simulations
and we want to postulate a model
based on
these coefficients beta which themselves
can be non-linear
but we're going to look at linear
combinations of them
and we have this t here our basis
tensors which need to be formulated by
the user based on knowledge of the
physics
and a couple key notes is that forming
this as a tall skinny vectors
ensures that the beta does not vary with
orientation so that's an important
ingredient for
form and variance
and
by doing a linear combination of the
basis functions guarantee is the
galilean invariance as well
and
what we do is a
sparse regression so essentially an
optimization where we have an l2 norm
where we regress the data onto the model
and then we add an l1 penalty uh in
order to induce sparsity so this ensures
instead of enslaving the data the model
to the data it'll identify which terms
are important and which terms play less
of a role which is quite useful
now
as i said we have these tensorbases and
the user needs to decide you know input
them
we see this as a feature because you
need to know something about the physics
and as opposed to um you know being
purely data driven
and in the context of single phase flow
you know if you look in for example uh
professor stephen pope's textbook you
can find a table of these basis tensors
that exist
and we in our physical review fluids
paper we demonstrate this method on a
single a bunch of single-phase flows and
shows that it works quite well and is
able to identify um
the algebraic models for the renal
stress terms using these these uh
basis tensors but the basis tensors for
multiphase flows
haven't yet been developed and so in our
uh a recent jfm paper sarah derived the
uh um non-dimensional symmetric diva
devatoric tensors for these coupled
fluid particle flows and so they're
basically a function of the relative
velocity and the reynolds stresses of
each phase
and this is an example of what the
simulations look like at point one
percent concentration of five percent
concentration
uh and so if we if we use this data from
the simulations and we look at what
sparse regression gives us is an example
of one of the terms this is that drag
production term
and we see here that we're able to come
up with a compact algebraic expression
based on in this case the mass loading
and
some of these tensor bases so based on
the relative velocities and it works
quite well across the volume fraction
and reynolds number
one thing we're curious about was all of
this simulation data is statistically
stationary so meaning the data we
provide it's average in time it's
essentially a single point and so it is
we took the simulations and we reversed
gravity and so we looked at the
transient behavior and here we're
looking at the the mean settling
velocity the particle phase versus time
and using the renal stress models from
the
stationary data
still gives us a very reasonable
prediction and so this is quite
promising
we're now using this approach
for more complex systems both on channel
flows uh and we have a recent paper
that's that'll be appear soon
online
uh looking at the heat transfer so here
we're looking at the effect of
clustering on the uh thermal entrance
length as you can imagine if you had a
uniform distribution of particles and a
temperature difference between the
phases
you would have a smaller entrance length
meaning the distance that the fluid
temperature relaxes to an equal
equilibrium compared to a more realistic
case we have strong clustering and we're
able to come up with new uh these
correlations for that entrance link in
addition to
um uh rental stress type models for the
for the temperature
and just a final note before i wrap up
here
one of the
challenges with the sparse regression is
that these the coefficients in beta need
to be input by the user and what we're
finding is that we can make use of gene
expression programming
i started to automate that process and
so sarah has an archive paper here
where we combine sparse regression with
gene expression programming and the idea
is
we still want to end up with a compact
algebraic
expression we want to um leverage the
the properties of the sparse regression
for the
form and variance
but we also want to automate some of the
challenging parts and so here
what we're doing is using a gene
expression programming to come up with
the coefficients appearing in beta in
order to come up with
more general expressions for them closed
terms
um
a couple notes on that uh gene
expression programming uh does not
enforce the relation that the models to
be linear with respect to the basis
tensors and so that's why sparse
regression is important to um guarantee
form and variance uh and so uh and
preliminary results are showing that if
you when you combine them
uh
it's
it's it's able to um it's a nice
compromise with with uh
at least um embedding certain physics
but also automating some of that process
and so
in conclusion uh you know we're talking
here about these
dispersed two-phase flows where the
particle phase has a strong effect on
the background turbulence uh the drag
force acting on a dense suspension
exhibits a large variation and so
treating the force stochastically is is
showing promise to guarantee certain
statistics like particle velocity
variance and dispersion
multiphase turbulence modeling
following traditional approaches of
directly averaging average stokes is is
challenging because it it really lumps a
lot of the physics into a small number
of terms um and so instead doing this
sort of
sequential approach of averaging locally
averaging number stokes and then rentals
averaging those intermediate equations
um is allows us to retain more physics
but it results in a large number of
unclosed terms that need to be uh um
modeled
and sparse regression is showing promise
for developing uh closures for those
terms
and uh with that i am happy to
take any questions that anyone might
have
thank you thank you so much for the
great talk um
jesse um we do have a
one question from um
gavin um he was wondering about what is
the gene uh expression programming oh
yeah yeah
i skimmed over that for two reasons
uh one is
it's very recent work um we have an
archive paper here but it's it's very
much um you know we're starting to look
into it so gene expression programming
is uh
it's a
considered and um
what's it called
a uh
sorry the word slip on my mind an
evolutionary algorithm in the sense it
it's a symbolic method and so it can
work with sine sine functions cosines
exponentials and so forth and it tries
to come up with um
uh
which what's the best combination of all
these various symbolic expressions
and there's very nice open source code
online so we basically took a
off-the-shelf
open source gene expression matlab code
to do this part
and the nice thing is uh you know you
can have options on how many terms and
how complex those terms are so without
the gene expression programming the user
would have to decide what those kind of
functional forms or combinations of
these coefficients might look like the
gene expression programming sort of
tries to determine what those
expressions are if that makes sense
that sounds really similar to
actually the work done by
one of our own
somehow i i
i
i forgot his name um
but he he did uh come up with a some
symbolic uh learning algorithm um
yeah this archive paper uh
sarah
goes through there's been a couple
people have used it for turbulence
modeling and not not many but there have
been a couple um
and i'm sure
you know it's i'm sure it's been used in
other areas as well
yeah i mean if i
it'll come back to me so if if
if his name comes back to me i will
hold his name so that maybe you guys can
connect it
okay um
all right i don't have any other
questions from from the chat room but i
have some of mine oh sure
before
before i go to
my questions um there's another question
from chandler
he said hey jesse
i really enjoyed reading your work on
stochastic drag modeling uh have you
have you put any thoughts towards
how two-point stated statistics between
uh particle positions and velocities
for example radial distribution
functions may impact your drag moments
i uh this is fantastic question and it's
exactly what we're looking at right now
and so
maybe to clarify to some folks
you can imagine having that you have a
suspension of particles that are going
to evolve with the flow and uh you know
one of the arguments i've been making is
some of these deterministic you know if
you have just two particles settling in
a viscous flow right the particle
upstream will fall in the wake of the
other particle and catch up and it's the
so-called uh drafting kissing tumbling
right so meaning if two particles near
each other they're going to be
influenced by each other's waves uh a
deterministic approach that directly
accounts for neighboring effects should
be able to capture that and i think
balashonda has shown that
a stochastic approach that i presented
here
won't right because we're sampling from
a a a distribution and so it doesn't
really have knowledge on the specific
pairwise interactions
but my argument's been well if we have
millions of particles who cares what we
care about is is getting the right
statistics
and that's something an argument i've
posed but but at the same time my
collaborator shane carson uranium
has been looking at connecting this
with two-point statistics and we believe
that it is possible in this sort of
language framework sarcastic framework
to um
capture the the radial distribution
function or the two point statistics
and the reason why i think it's
extremely exciting is because
um it's commonplace in in industry and
and throughout academia to do reynolds
average number stokes right
you do rams for the fluid and they do
lagrangian particle tracking and then
you do a random stochastic random walk
models for the for the particles to say
my fluid
has an unresolved uh turbulent motion
i'm going to treat it stochastically
those methods can't capture preferential
concentration
they're unable to get these pairwise
interactions and i think
this might be a missing link
but it's something we're just now
starting to look at and i think it's a
really exciting direction
i hope i hope that answers your question
i hope that answers uh the chancellor's
questions um
okay he said thank you okay
right okay um another question from um
maxwell um he asked is there any
technical reason why radiation is
neglected in the chemical looking
vector that's a good question um
because it's hard
so
uh a lot of everything i've shown up to
this point has been isothermal
and if you look at the um you know the
actual these experiments also are
isothermal but obviously the motivating
example is a thermally evolving you know
catalytic
type of reactor right so chemical
looping reactors are
operated at elevated temperature where
radiation is likely important and
obviously you know stanford has been
doing a lot of great work on this in
recent years
mostly in the dilute limit
so
here we're looking at convection
and we neglected radiation uh mostly
saying that uh you know clustering
affects the turbulence and that's going
to affect the infected transport of the
the temperature but you're absolutely
right the radiation will play
a role at high enough temperatures and i
think there's
there's a lot of good work to be done in
these denser suspensions i don't know of
any really good models that exist for
radiative transport when you have these
denser suspensions and you can imagine
it's difficult because um
you have a lot in terms of you know when
you model radiation you you have to
account for you do monte carlo type of
simulations of all these angles and here
you're going to have
deflections off of all the surfaces of
the particles and it becomes an end body
problem
so
yeah it's it's an area of research i
think that that's very exciting um
where would be exciting i i don't know
how how much is being pursued now at
least at these volume fractions
i see thank you thank you jesse um
okay i don't see any question from
chatroom um i have a question about the
scalability you said um
you're tackling the larger scale problem
uh with the particle flow um how the
what is what was the largest largest
problem you could uh solve yeah
i didn't do a good job i think ex
talking about the um
the simulations we were running right so
here
we're doing two things one was a
stochastic modeling and that framework
is used to
for us to run these more canonical
simulations to generate data now it
turns out
that and then i glanced over this um
when we scale up i showed that
homogeneous heating and cooling rate of
order of 100 particles and there the
stochastic model plays a big role it
turns out for this cluster-induced
turbulence most of the heterogeneity is
driven by the larger scale cluster
dynamics so in that case the stochastic
modeling actually plays a little role in
the existing drag models do a pretty
good job and so the simulations were
performing for to generate the data so
these homogeneous simulations
the channel flow i showed and these heat
transfer simulations
are
on the order of you know we're tracking
individual particles
on the order of i think 30 million
particles for this case um we've we've
gone up to 500 million particles is
probably the largest we've done
um because they're you know there are
grid spacings on the order of the
particle diameter
but
even at that those scales
we're never gonna tackle um
the uh you know reactor scales and
that's why
we're doing the reynolds averaging right
and so if we look here
those hundred million particle
simulations that's to generate these
mesoscale simulations to generate the
data
and we're applying it to look at um
rand's types of frameworks that could be
applied here and that's where
um we haven't this is the direction i
want to go is actually start applying
them in in
rand solvers right everything to date
has been more we've we've developed
algebraic models but not actually tested
them at full scale and that's that's an
area i'm hoping to look at today
yeah yeah sounds good thank you uh we do
have a another questions
um
from maxwell again why is the
performance of this approach for cases
where the fluid and particle velocities
are very
close in magnitude
sorry repeat that
he asked why is the performance of this
approach for cases where the fluids
and particle velocities are very close
in magnitude so the
the difference between the fluid and
particle velocity is you know what we
call the slip velocity or the drift
velocity
um need not be small right so the the
particle reynolds numbers characterized
based on that velocity difference
and it turns out in these sort of cases
with clustering what you get is the the
particles entrain the flow and that
leads to smaller slip velocity and
reduce drag and that's sort of the
origin of the clustering itself
but outside the clusters uh um the the
slip velocities are quite different
meaning we have particle reynolds
numbers upwards of 50.
um
if you so that's based on the slip
velocity and then the particle diameter
and the viscosity
so so
this we're specifically looking at cases
where we have finite slip velocity
otherwise we wouldn't have uh turbine
kinetic energy produced by the particles
now
you know some in this community in the
incompressible flow world
uh particle renault number 50 is usually
considered quite high
but i i don't know if you're maybe if
your background is more incompressible
flows you know or you know you think
about ballistics those particle reynolds
numbers go up to you know
most drag laws go up to 200 000 and uh
you know it's that's a very different
type of regime here
all right
okay thank you jesse uh another question
from fatty
uh will you be considering uh magnus
forces as the particle rotates um may
you comment on the coli collision model
in yeah yeah
yeah
i thought i would be really
originally too many slides um
i ever so i removed slides and talked
really fast and ended much earlier than
i thought but uh so our the clash of
model we use a classic sauce for your
collision model the idea is particles
are treated as a mass spring damper so
our simulation time step is restricted
such that particles can't move more than
one tenth of diameter per time step and
so
this is essentially we can account for
rotation
and
inelastic
collisions and the reason we use a soft
sphere model is because in these types
of flows you can have sustained contact
with multiple particles and so a hard
sphere type of approach might have a
hard time with that
but the idea of these lift forces is a
good one
we find in general uh you know in terms
of lift you have safman lift so you have
gradients in the fluid that can induce
lift and then you have magnus lift
meaning the particle is spinning and
that can induce lift
usually for these gas solid flows high
density ratio those are
usually not very important and so a long
time ago i looked at magnus lift and it
was really playing almost no role here
but with that said we've we have a
collaboration with a felipe coletti
who's doing uh simulations of of uh
of riser flows and ducks uh so
wall-bounded flows in this sort of
regime of like what near one percent
concentration
and uh
really nice particle tracking
velocimetry and so forth and we're
finding that when you have wall-bounded
flow lift might be more important um and
so we're sort of doing a
sensitivity analysis now on on those
various forces but i don't think magnus
is playing much of a role here
and uh and to be clear our particle
rotation is only due to collisions so
when particles collide there's a
tangential component that can induce
rotation
we don't have
any fluid coupling for the torque but
again the density ratios usually have
2000 so it should be quite small so i
don't think magnus effects can be very
large for these flows
okay thank you thank you very much jesse
um i i do not see any other questions um
um chat room so
i don't know that doesn't mean uh
it don't
yeah but like i said i'm happy to take
any questions offline um
yeah uh and yeah and i do wanna mention
my so my postdoc aaron is uh he's
currently on the job market and he's
restricting himself to the california
region
so uh um and he's fantastic he's
absolutely fantastic so i just wanted to
mention that before i uh before i sign
off
all right that sounds good well uh let's
thank our speaker uh jesse today huh
what a wonderful talk i mean the the
the simulations you're dealing with is
is really complicated and
and i think you are doing wonderful
research right now okay thank you so
much
and uh with that uh we're gonna end
our ddps seminar today and uh next dps
seminar is going to be next week so
please stay tuned and
yes um
thank you thank you everyone thank you
jesse
thanks again